joey virtue says love the show i'm
curious about how you three stand on
guns for soft protection home defense
also what state in the u.s what uh would
you three
move to uh you go first uh i'm for guns
i i understand the need to protect
yourself in
you know areas that aren't congested i
mean even in
those kind of areas there's there are
hot heads that are crazy
and any anyone can can go crazy at any
point honestly and it's like
i don't know yeah i'm four guns i
honestly it's more for
like hunting and protecting yourself if
you need bee
but you know it makes sense if if we're
gonna live off the land
you know hunting's part of it i mean
obviously i'm vegan so it's kind of
weird to hear a vegan talk about hunting
but
you know not everybody is vegan so i
understand the need to get your own food
and i think that's a big part of it and
yeah home defense it's like
i mean we were living in miami and we
weren't
necessarily out in the country country
we were like an hour outside miami and
someone broke into our backyard and was
like looking around with a flashlight
and
i mean we we didn't know who this person
was what if they had a gun what if they
were coming at us to like steal our
stuff it's like
we were not close like if we called the
police like they probably wouldn't have
been there 40 minutes
yeah i mean we knows how long it would
take for them to get there so we also
had those reports of the home invasion
exactly some somebody got murdered oh
even worse
right right yeah so like what were we
doing we took your airsoft rifle
that we had there you actually we had a
handheld pistol
version of it too yeah and we were
standing on the back porch like who's
out there
well i cracked it and dry fired oh yeah
yeah that's right that was yeah that
that was an aggressive that was a good
22.
it was yeah yeah yeah so and then you
know what happened
the person left i ran off he ran off
yeah he didn't come into our house
i went outside i screamed and i went
bang right and they were gone
screaming you know so but i've been i've
been criticized for that too and i'm
like look man i did what i did at the
time
situation i didn't know what the right
thing to do was yeah some people have
said like you got to be careful like
you know that could have alerted them to
then like maybe sneak up an attack or
something and i'm like
they were coming at and they were
probably snooping on my prop
on our property yeah in in in it was a
big it was a five acre property
we had neighbors and all that but it was
like it was
you know when you were in the in the
back by like there's like a barn
building yeah
you're it's like yeah what do you do you
can't you can't even get back there
normally
and so you have to like find your way in
someone jumped over
like a six-foot fence with also plants
growing around we never opened yep
and they were snooping around looking in
the barn and stuff and we saw the light
flickering it was like midnight you're
making a pizza
yeah and so i was like yo and i was like
dude
and we all saw and we were like whoa
dude yeah and so i was like i grabbed
it was like a remington i think and i
went broke the bear i went outside and
went hey
bang and then rustling running yep over
the fence and going yeah exactly
and so i was talking to some friends
that you feel the same way i do then
yeah absolutely yeah
and i was i was explaining to my friend
who said you know told me that there's
no reason
it's a liberal hollywood type there's no
reason for anyone ever have a gun and i
was like let me tell you a story
yeah i told the story and i said what
should i have done like
if i didn't have a weapon and i was like
it wasn't even it wasn't even a real
and they did have a weapon not that we
know that they did or not but
there's a high probability that they did
have a weapon and what if they were
coming to rob us you know
and maybe they heard the shot and we're
like it's not worth it because
i don't want to get shot yep they might
have still had a weapon exactly so i
you know i ask this there's no good
answer it's like oh well call the police
they'll be there in 40 minutes
it's like well what if there was all
guns were gone then you wouldn't have to
worry about it anymore you can't stop
them
exactly so people can 3d print a gun now
that that's viable to it's not a
one-shot cracked when it's done
it's like replace the mag keep shooting
it looks like a vector
submachine gun it's probably not uh
shotguns but shotguns make sense
you know for like home defense stuff but
ultimately it's like
shotguns do make sense because you can
hunt certain kinds of uh
deer or not deer um doves and stuff on
the fence
but you can also use it at home like
dave chappelle bird chat bird shot
buckshot bro
that's right yeah so this this idea that
we could just call the police
i was like we the nearest store right
for us to buy food
yeah at least 15 minutes oh no the gas
station right no it was seven miles away
no there was a liquor store
that was a mile oh okay that was the
only thing though when i wanted to get
milk or something it'd be like the gas
station is seven
miles away so what do you think's gonna
happen if you call the police they're
gonna be like well reach out to somebody
they can be there in 20 or 30 minutes
there's someone in my backyard
i can't see them i don't they they're
looking around in my barn with a
flashlight
okay what do you want are they armed i
don't know i don't i don't can't see
you know what you know what the cops
will probably say do you have any
weapons in the home
that's true get it that's that's true
that wouldn't surprise me when somebody
came here at four in the morning
like i'm i'm when we're in jersey yeah
the cops came and they were like we're
gonna we're gonna take care of
everything
yeah and one of the guys one of the cops
was like you know sitting there
listening
and then i was like i called you guys as
soon as i could and the guy goes if for
me i would answer the door with my
shotgun
and i was like so i should get a shock
and he's like if it were me i'd answer
my door with a shotgun
he didn't answer the question but he
answered the question but he answered
the question
and so i did you know uh but they gave
me the run around at the local
department about
you know getting a weapon yeah and uh to
be honest it's kind of like my fault for
not going and following up
okay i work too much but uh i went there
and they did not make it easy
and they told me to film to get a gun to
write an essay
all right so where what in the states
where where would i live
um west virginia we were talking about
west virginia every time
i see the the river shenandoah i just
get all happy for some reason
i start singing i start singing country
roads in my head i was a fallout fan
for a long time so i still am west
virginia
has got good internet in certain areas
yeah
and it seems like a good place to start
something up
yeah i mean but there's no airports
there's no big
there are just not big ones yeah true
it's not there's no yeah there's no big
it's not like we could eventually have
guests normally well we could but it
would be a
general plan you fly to dc then you fly
on the regional
you know what i mean little tiny hey man
joe's talking about going to texas
people will go if they want you know
texas has got plenty of
big cities and big uh airports it's true
it's rich
we drove through it it's funny there's
like the northern strip of west virginia
that's like 40 miles
yeah it's like you just like go right
right through it yeah i thought we were
going through the heart of
when we drove when we drove to l.a and
it's like we drive through and i'm like
oh we're in west virginia wow
we'll check it out it's like we're not
in anymore now leaving
right when you thought that now leaving
west virginia that's funny that's small
you know i grew up we we're both from
chicago yeah and the crazy thing about
chicago is that for the longest time it
was outright illegal
to own guns like i mean in the city for
yeah it was like it was really really
difficult to do anything with guns they
were like
it was it was legal technically yeah
and they got really mad when the supreme
court struck it down being like saying
you can't ban these
weapons and stuff right but there was a
story of uh a woman from tennessee
who had i think like oh yeah get a
revolver she went to the sears tower
yeah willis whatever it's a serious time
she was some old lady in her sister og
chicago and sears tower she's an old
lady
she has a legal permit for the weapon in
tennessee she was on vacation she just
drove up
she went to the tower they have a metal
detector they said do you have any
weapons who does i do i have my revolver
they rest around the spot
last i heard you got four years what
really
yeah that's what i heard i knew a dude
who was this is the story i was told
that's sad i feel bad for her
so this is an anecdote that somebody
told me it's like i pulled up the
records
but there was a dude who um lived in
california okay and had legal weapons
and he was driving across the country
right and he got pulled over in illinois
and the cops said you have weapons i do
he was driving through illinois on his
way to the east coast okay
and the cop said you know open it up saw
that the guy had some rifles and some
handguns and he's like you're under
arrest
felony possession and you got four years
what i have family members
in illinois that live in illinois that
have guns and they're
they're legal they you know and you have
a concealed carry and there's even
supposed to be
like laws about you know safe transport
yeah
dude got railroaded didn't care it's
ridiculous they
i think they accuse him of like trying
to sell weapons or something they were
like nope we don't believe you
you have too many and he was like i'm le
i'm not even staying in illinois and i
don't care
no he ended up getting probation though
so they were like suspended sentence
probation
so it's crazy because now it's like the
dude had to live in illinois
yeah it's like he gets out and they're
like you live here now for the next four
years and he was like
what what am i supposed to do choose to
live in illinois
now i could make some points about why i
think what happened happened and i think
what do you what do you know about
illinois
only what tim's told me and driving
through there i can't oh dude not
at all because they'll pull you over and
then you're in deep trouble i've had
cops playing with my all right
oh yeah i still have lots of good
memories of illinois and i like
illinois still so watch your mouth i'll
just i'll just leave it at this
this this dude and again this could be
apocryphal it could be what
it could have been lying to me but this
is what i heard from this guy he was a
skater
and uh he was not white and he got
pulled over in the south
southern illinois all right so i'm not
saying that's necessarily why but like
it's what you know the story ended up
being right
yeah so i'll tell you what man i've had
uh cops pull me over
at gunpoint in chicago when i was
covering nato protests with a bunch of
my friends
yeah searched the vehicle they raided
our apartment
right they tried to plant they they
tried to use a criminal informant or our
confidential informant to plant drugs in
our car
jeez and i know this this is confirmed
well there's good cops and bad cops
and nbc when we got when we got raided
when they surrounded us at gunpoint we
filmed and gave it to local nbc who
aired it
oh wow that video is up you can look up
the videos from nbc news
and yeah it's funny uh we came back to
the apartment lights were on it doesn't
sound fun tops had been there
it's messed up funny not funny haha
funny isn't like you whoa that's weird
you know what i mean okay like funny
strange yeah i
they searched our vehicle i think i know
what they were trying to do so long
story short
somebody shows up to the apartment we're
staying at because they were staying
there too is this
someone we knew okay and asks that they
can come with us
because we're leaving we're like we're
getting we're gtfo and we just got
surrounded by cops that was nuts we
don't want
we don't want to mess around they had
just you know uh black-sided 10 guys
okay i think it was 10 guys i don't know
how many people it was a bunch of people
filmed the cops and then often
disappeared
and then they got ended up getting
charged with terror terrorism like a
small handful of them okay
so we were like we're not going to stick
around to find out we don't know what
happened
so this dude tries coming and then i set
a bunch of rules
i said because of what just happened we
are going to everything's going to be
meticulous
no one is bringing anything perishable
you got vitamins flush them
garbage don't care yeah the only thing
coming in this are hard items like
clothing your computers your equipment
yeah and no one is going in the
apartment but me and i was with uh luke
rokowski i was like me and luke because
we are both
you know public figures yeah if anything
happens we can we have a better chance
of mustering a defense
so this dude tries going in the house
arguing that he needs to grab something
mm-hmm
later it turns i said no absolutely not
and he was like really
really pressuring me and then uh
i ultimately said if you go in that
house you will not get in our vehicle
and he said fine the next day it turns
out a con
uh who we believe to be was a police
informant kept begging him to bring
drugs into our car
and he was going to do it but they were
saying things like please just grab this
for me i just need this
just just grab it so i can pick it up
from you tomorrow in
illinois there's mandatory drug
sentencing if we had that in our vehicle
so i wonder if that had something to do
with us getting pulled over
i ultimately don't know but i saw the
text messages where the
person wow was like do this dang
and he was saying stuff like i can't
they're not letting me it's like please
you have to do this for me you have to
do this now
you wouldn't do it that's chicago man i
don't wanna you're not gonna mess around
i know i know the secret uh mobster
handshake in chicago
old school chicago do they still use it
i i have no idea but i know it used to
be a thing like back in the day you
would like walk up and
you know the guys stand in the bouncer
and you just like welcome give him the
handshake give him the specific
handshake and
he'll let you in no way
[Laughter]
keeping that that close that's right
keeping it up i'll show you after the
show if you want
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode